[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
merci beaucoup monsieur domestique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui madame passion romantique d'avoir de
près aux dieux je l'aperçois c'était je
ne suis pas déçu elle est brune elle est
belle cette madame bridge à qui j'ai
bien l'honneur de parler répondait ce
serait un bonheur
mais oui monsieur asseyez-vous
merci
vous remarquez que je reste à distance
vous témoigne enfin si respect et
déférence
néanmoins je voudrais savoir aider ce le
jour quel est votre façon de concevoir
l'amour par tomber êtes vous pour un
seul grand amour dans la vie pas de
mettez vous madame
et selon votre envie la moindre
défaillance en un corps vertueux madame
répondait car j'ai suis curieux je
comprends eh bien monsieur jeanne mais
sous certaines réserves la défaillance
mais de toute façon ça n'est jamais la
faute de la femme c'est toujours celle
du mar comme vous avez raison écrivait
monsieur comment écrivez ce que je vous
dise ans avoue le répéterai mal de
répéter dans votre article dans mon art
et dan dare dare de quelle façon je
conçois l'amour vous est venue
m'interviewer pour votre enquête de la
veillée des chaumières
l'adultère chez la femme fidèle du tout
madame de l'état journalistes le maire
de quel droit composez-vous semblables
question du droit qu'à un homme quel
qu'il soit dont l'envi et de connaître
enfin la femme de sa vie
avancer votre main prenez ces quelques
roses et le son du matin tout
fraîchement éclos en les roses toujours
comme les églantines jeudi éviterait et
la prochaine fois je vous apporterai
deux ou trois pétunias pardon à ne sont
que vous partiez quelques jours ils
flottent autour de vos une atmosphère
d'amour vous avez vous senti à cette
étape prodige le vendredi 1er vers 5
heures au claridge vous avez vous senti
le 12 aux acacias ou porter un chapeau
avec des petits pois l avez-vous senti à
mon dieu quelle odeur hier soir au
théâtre où l'on jouait pas ce talent ça
monsieur vous aperçu à garder la fayette
et depuis pour toujours vous êtes dans
ma tête oui
c'est une ça vous ne me croyez pas elle
ne le crois pas dis plutôt aux marins
qui n'aiment pas la mer va trouver sur
son banc le forçat qui s'ennuient dit vu
qu'il n'aime pas la main qui le délivre
mais ne me dis jamais que je ne t'aime
pas ça devrait me plaît ça ne rime plus
non madame ça ne rime pas mais l'amour
c'est un ami rime ni raison
écoutez monsieur moi je n'ai pas de
temps à perdre et puis mon mari va
rentrer d'un instant à l'autre je vous
en ferai bien comment tout ce que je
vous dis mon romantisme maaf l'homme
mais rose mais épineux rien de vous tous
les fichiers mais si je ne vous connais
pas herman vous savez les verts les
grandes banques
la passion n'est pas votre genre vendre
est ce qu'il vous faut
levis vous n'a pas tu m'as unique
rien que des divans bas comme pôle
opinion sur les tables des livres
érotiques et parterres des tapis
moelleux nos plateformes de glace
zooland fn à billes en métal ou détaille
ses deux poupées habillées en haïti
gueule et qui fume la pipe ou des
pervers effroyable et daily show vous
êtes des gouttes d'eau jusque vous
voulez que je sois le passé en tout cas
alors par roméo par le marquis de sade
werther le désespoir
qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est la
chose avec laquelle j'ai l'habitude de
me tuer
c'est un vol vous ne voulez pas de moi
pourquoi vivre
pourquoi vidéo écoutez monsieur vous est
insupportable si on ne me supportais pas
longtemps voulez-vous me passer mon
revolver je vous prie il est vilain
n'ouvrait pas grand mal gélébart y
rester une femme c'est moi j'ai horreur
des gens qui se tuent satellite eux
c'est encore très bien j'ai ce qu'il
vous faut
l'argent et je ris chat mignon petit
mais si tu te donnes à moi il n'est pas
été qu'un foyer semaine saurait
satisfaire cet intéressant il ne croit
pas voici les liasses plus bas sur des
liens il s'en faut naturellement ils
sont fous lorsque celle ci c'est pour le
geste mais j'en ai devrait chez moi
petit venir chez moi et que je découvre
da écoutez monsieur je voudrais bien que
vous en aviez soit reste la violence
fait la garde toujours pour la fin parce
que j répugne et puisqu'il le faut
[Rires]
décidément rien à faire avec vous je me
tue à vous divertir
j'aurais fait ce que j'ai pu vous êtes
témoin de chez vous vous permettez que
je ramasse mais accessoires chez vous
bonjour ma chérie
qu'est-ce qui se passe kenneth nation
c'est monsieur jamais manqué de respect
de 5 face aux différentes je te serais
reconnaissant de flanquer la force et
bien laisse moi avec monsieur ne fait
pas trop brutale tout mais je crois
qu'il est un peu fou il a déjà reçus de
jls moi je sais ce que j'ai à faire pour
qui la drague et vous monsieur pour
qu'ils apprennent et vous monsieur
alors ben alors mon vieux rien à faire
ta femme est la plus honnête de la terre
jamais ne trompera tu as vraiment fait
tout ce que tu as pu moi j'ai essayé
toutes les manières possibles
la passion le vice le désespoir
l'argent la force là résisté à tout et
puis il va résister à moi à moi un
spécialiste bah c'est bien pour ça qu'il
m'avait choisi pas une seconde
elle n'a paru même légèrement troublée
j'espère que content a enchanté tient
raté 58 à merci as tu peux être
enchantés on peut sur que sa femme c'est
pas donné à tout le monde y à part ça il
va bien pas méritoire rush d'ubs ont
aidé à faire ce match si ça marche tu
vois le type à la lanterne sourde et oui
c'est moi sommes passés par semblant
ça fait rien et mon nom dessus et comme
tu le vois je surprends le criminel que
tu dis que tu dises alors je suis
content je suis détective mon ami et
voilà l'image de ma vie j'ai eu mes
compliments pastor besoin de moi sur le
malawi à la fin de ses jours
bon je te raccompagna vais faire gérer
une commission affaire très importante
et félicie m'a chargé de te dire que
l'avait reconnu le bouton de tons pâles
tout bon dieu fait ici dit qu'elle a
reconnu le bouton de mon paletot
approchez vous fait des confidences
c'est un langage chiffrées ça veut dire
que et elle me fait dire sa part le
patron
ça veut dire qu elle m'attend à 6 heures
dans sa chambre ah oui je couche avec la
bonne moira but des amours ancillaires
que voulez vous j'en suis arrivé là
un tri tribu tu as vu ma nouvelle
affiche vrille où je ne vois pas moi et
c'est dommage toi tu es si toi au bureau
tu travailles
ah oui je suis un auxiliaire obscures
est sacrifiée c'est moi qui travaille
c'est vous qui êtes sur la jugent comme
dans la vie c'est normal rabbit les
amères support à mersch une résine et
des depuis 30 ans c'est moi qui suis las
de cette agence les jeunes gagnent des
800 francs par mois et 800 feront pas
moi-même en 1923
car nous sommes en 1923 et ben c'est pas
beaucoup je fais tout et je ne suis rien
il fait tout par répand et assassin du
baron poche en 1904 qui l'a découvert
mon nom - - toujours moi il s'attire de
l'impératrice d'autriche en 1910 qui l'a
découvert hu a toujours moi et alors mon
nom que nous faisait rieur
rien du tout il en faisait plus que vous
c'était un homme de métier il avait été
chargé en ville à 17 ans vous n'avez
même pas été sage en 2020 pourquoi ne me
tutoie du port tu vas quoi des
tout-petits ans par espèce et par mépris
je vous méprise en beauté bien aimable
mais pourquoi me raconte tout cela va se
jouer la justice c'est moi qui aurais
vieux hérité de cette agence à la mort
de votre on est tu veux arrêter comme
socrate est non pourquoi
bompard coupe du monde 1-1 étourdi un
incapable
et bien vois-tu à quel point je te suis
super fière tu n'aurais pas pris à cause
de mes défauts et moi je te garde malgré
les triant banderoles et mis en tulle et
jaloux sournois vulgaire et insolent nul
autre que moi ne supporterai alors tu
vois quelle chance tu as
que ce soit moi qui ai hérité de lagence
de mon oncle par exemple week en voilà
assez
parlons un peu des affaires courantes je
te prie - a as-tu pensé à clara bouchard
bien à bouchaoui jeter prié de retrouver
coûte que coûte une personne qui
s'appelle clara bouchard et qui habitait
en 1913 26 rue quincampoix tu te
rappelles plus brillantes ouvrez votre
printemps vraiment moi j'ai retrouvé la
rue cas pourquoi j'ai même retrouvé le
numéro 26 il approuvait le numéro 26
faut le faire
eh ben je vais faire
pour le reste n'est entendu alors qu'est
ce que c'est que cette pierre à bouche
ça ne regarde pas c'est une affaire a
déjà fait à propos propos et le sautoir
de la duchesse de gauche le doute d'un
buzz a téléphoné ce matin pour avoir des
nouvelles
tu lui en a donné en aviez-vous le
voleur dusautoir n'est pas un voleur
mais la fin de la duchesse de jeunes oui
il était dans sa chambre et il a volé
pour justifier sa présence
oui c'est un truc qui l'avait faire dans
nos bons villageois de victorien sardou
non c'est pas cette pièce là c'est une
autre qui s'appelle redoublions année le
voilà le sautoir de la duchesse de 2,6
puis oula tu trouvé dans son écrin mais
quand mardi dernier à minuit
c'est le jour et l'heure du vol
parfaitement 7 à 20 ans n'ait pas
compris c'est bien simple la soirée
débute de beige avait lieu mardi dernier
à 10 heures l'après midi je m'habille en
plombier avant et tout en réparant paul
de fuite de gaz car j ignore tout des
fuites de gaz
j'examine l'appartement bien le soir je
m'habille en général kozak
on m'annonce je suis reçue admirablement
je m'isole quelques instants au lavabo
et je m'habille en soubrettes en
soubrette
oui ça me va divinement jeu peut
pénétrer dans la chambre de la duchesse
de beige et je vole le sautoir comme si
je faisais la couverture ensuite pour
sortir de l'appartement
je m'habille en maître d'hôtel et je
sors avec les extras de la maison poteau
et shabelle alors si c'est toi qui a
volé les sautoirs c'est moi qui revient
sur toi de la duchesse de buzz voilà une
idée pourquoi mais pour vous malheureux
pour vous rendre pour la jambre
territoire a dû aller c'est bien ça
depuis que vous êtes à la tête de cette
agence
on ne découvre plus rien sans rien de
sensationnel nous sommes au bord de la
faillite
la maison va péricliter alors que frère
du fonds promo ses atouts faut surtout
penser à moi comment vivrait ge alors
j'ai pensé à voler le sautoir de la
duchesse de beige un demi million est un
terrible
les journaux sont pleins alors vous
retrouvez le sautoir puisque vous êtes
le patron vous le remettez au duc de
gauche qui vous remet son tour les 20
mille francs promis et que vous aurez la
délicatesse de me remettre à moi tout au
moins je l'espère oui je t'en donnerai
la moitié sera là bien du temps de votre
ongle on ne remet tait rien trop bas à
cet égard il ya du progrès alors qu'est
ce que vous en dites je dis que je te
justifier la confiance que je témoigne
et que si tu n'avais pas une idée comme
ça de temps en temps qu'est ce que tu
fais ici je dois d'abord un vous êtes un
minable
attention rejoindre votre groupe vous a
laissé un peu d'inertie
bien non laisse moi s'il te plait je
travaille je veux tu t'en aller décide
non gitans donner des chiffres
j'ai attaqué tout à l'heure c'est très
grave enfin mon dieu qu'est-ce qu'il ya
frais qu'elle a fait sur la peau d'ours
beke a fait sur la peau de ce flic avait
son labo jours c'est tout commence et
tout c'est la première fois que ça lui
arrive toujours il attend qu'on le sente
me suis très bien j'ai peur qu'elle soit
mal mais c'est pour ça que tu me dérange
en bourse a tué son coeur cet instant au
coeur il s'agit d'un petit chien que
nous avons depuis le début de notre
mariage et recomptent jusqu'à 10 et
cesser les crimes wadah khanfar mais ne
répond qu'elle s'en fiche
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ça que vous
pensez de ça et bien moi madame d'abed
je vois que vous avez des choses
importantes à vous dire
alors je m'éclipse
écoute yvonne ça n'est plus possible
ça n'est plus possible une fois pour
toutes je t'ai priés de ne pas venir
dans mon bureau quand j'ai du monde du
foot est malade c'est autrement plus
importants que ceux d'il y avait six as
tu as raison cet avis il s'agit enfin de
toute façon je te dispense de porté des
appréciations sur mes collaborateurs
alors tu auras fait de venir le voir
10 à fric fric zut confie qu'elle gîte
pour fêter et zut pour la peau d'ours et
j'ai à travailler voilà et si les
manades téléphonant vétérinaire mais pas
d'ici va téléphoner dans ta chambre tu
écris morrison viennent prendre le thé à
5h respecte aura fini de travailler oui
peut-être gens sérieux messieurs je vous
avais demandé de suivre ma femme vous
avez suivi ma tante vous êtes honnêtes
ou courriel elle se développe
j'ai toujours dit qu'il était pas fait
pour être détective privé veux-tu me
[ __ ] le corps oh c'est bon ça va
oh là là c'est pas de pot de vraiment
gentils avec moi
vraiment tu sais quelques jours de ça je
dis oui mais la date nous avons eu 17
mais allez on le dit et on a 17 mai et
alors et donc aujourd'hui un énorme nous
sommes mardi
ah oui tiens tu vas acheter quelque
chose mais quoi
de winne
ben moi ça mais enfin c'est le sautoir
de la duchesse de buzz
il voit un demi million je suppose tout
de même pas eu les moyens tu sais
comment comment es tu saïfi nous l'avons
voulons qu'ils rabut et moi à tous cette
valeur voyez-vous les arrêts style queen
mais comme nous ne restions plus nous a
dit sèchement la personne ne regarde pas
qu'est ce que tu m'as frappant notre
anniversaire de mariage
je vais t'offrir un appartement
nous déménageons bitume a grandi ici mes
bureaux vont absorber les chambres et
les salles ont alors nous habiterons
ailleurs et je viendrai ici tous les
jours pour mes affaires
charmant alors tu quitteras la maison de
9h à 12h de deux heures à 7 heures je te
verrai jamais voilà la vie tu me
réservent à moins que tu as far moi qui
ne vit que pour toi yvonne je désire te
causer sa minute
machaie gijon
ah non pas maintenant mon mari désire me
parler cinq minutes foutez nous la paix
je qui téléphonaient le préfet de police
à perdre autant de beauté police avait
rejoint
mais en face à non alors mon préfet
salomon préfet panneaux il est parti au
nom tu sais rien mais que tu désires m'a
parlé j'ai luan les jeunes à rester coup
ma chérie vont nous nous sommes
rencontrés pour la première fois il ya
18 mois le 15 août au casino de
deauville
on a présenté à moi je t'ai invités pour
le premier chimie et les huitièmes
mesure tum acheté par terre c'est toi
qui nous a fait tomber tu avais perdu
ton souligné parce que tu as fait
marcher dessus
tu avais des souliers trop large grand
marché fois parce qu'il me faisait mal
ne disputeront pas le résultat est que
nous avons été ridicules devant tout
paris en ce sens du but allemand moi
aussi et de ce jour nous avons cessé de
nous saluer six mois se passe mon oncle
meurt on ouvre son testament médias
sujet dit qu'est ce que tu dis mais
qu'est ce que j'y lis un articule de
l'article ici que j'hérite de son agence
et de sa fortune mais à la condition que
j'épouse une demoiselle yvonne de
moreuil dont il avait aimé la mer je ne
te permet de te dire du mal de ma maman
elle n'a jamais trompé papa
ainsi avec mon oncle neuf mois avant la
naissance c'est des bottes
alors pourquoi mon nom que se serait-il
intéressé à ce point là ton avenir force
qu'il était l'ami intime de mon père
nous sommes d'accord là dessus je
demande à connaître rejoint celle de
moreuil et qu'est-ce que je retrouve la
jeune femme qui m'a fait tomber le 15
août à deauville de vente où paris est
toi qui m'a fait tomber d'arrêt
permettant souliers tout avait marché si
tu avais des souliers trop large
on l'a déjà dit on l'a déjà dit oui
alors on est enfin son poids dans ces
conditions et nous détestons avant même
de nous marier
comment se fait-il que tu est conçu pour
moi une affection aussi exclusive ect
ect
l'oisiveté exclusive aussi tyrannique
aussi embêtante
alors tu me reproches de paix mais mais
non alors ça devient non je suis la
femme la plus fidèle la plus et mende et
c'est pourtant entendre me le reprocher
mais je ne dois pas ça non mais moi qui
ai supporté tout qui est passé surtout
parce qu'on nous qu'est ce que tu me
fais voir depuis que je te connais tu
m'as fait tomber le 15 ou tu avais perdu
ton souliers parce que tu as fait
marcher dessus avait des souliers trop
là on a déjà dit on l'a déjà dit us de
tous les maux des détectives et tu
t'appelles pas comment veto repos je
m'appelle bridge tête appelle briques
parce que tu as fait traduire ton nom en
anglais mais tu t'appelles pas victor
prendre
un détective se doit d'avoir un nom
anglais heureusement mais sur le
registre de l'état civil je m'appelle
madame bon c'est agréable
je couche avec le pont
ça vaut mieux être cochée dessous il est
arrivé et a mis en garde qu'il est
amusant
bref j'ai tout supporter à commencer par
la victime si elle tombe et demande le
divorce
c'est cette fois contents ils méritent
pas la femme que je sens la petite femme
timbrée veuve du préfet me débarrasser
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe bonjour
bonjour que la ville c'est parce que ma
vie est un enfer
mon prime pas nous déménageons il
s'appelle le pont et friqué avec son app
au doute
moi je suis trop malin qu'est ce qui a
donc encore bonjour mon vieux bonjour
chers amis encore une scène mais elle
est insupportable
elle m'a fait tomber à deauville elle
renvoie mes clients l orgueil le préfet
au téléphone mais elle fait sur la peau
d'ours n'ont cessé fric est alors tu là
bas mais non mon jeu je n'ai même pas
pensé mais elle a dit ça comme
l'araignée autre chose parce qu'elle est
insupportable c'est là qu'elle m'a non
non non
deux femmes ensemble vous allez la
beauté vous montez la tête
réciproquement
avant après elle sera encore plus odieux
ce fervent vas-y toi pourquoi moi mais
parce que tu es un un calmant un
pondérer si si si si si et puis elle tu
écoute beaucoup je l'ait remarqué
allez vas-y vas-y en rouge ça allait
vraiment eu série charmant une
commission c'est bien pour vous faire
plaisir allez allez on a l'habitude avec
les élèves
allez vas-y mon corps à tout un peu oui
à tout à l'heure oui allez vas-y vas-y
alors non victoire je vous mets mais je
ne pense qu'à vous moi je vous adore
alors tout va bien tout va mal comment
tout va mal et vous venez d'avoir une
scène violente avec votre femme
mais c'était une scène d'amour elle m'a
je riais parce qu'elle-même trop et vous
moi votre mari sa une un jury
plus madore et à mes pieds c'était
épouvantable sortiront jamais si il faut
s'en sortir mais nous aimons nous en
sommes juré d'être l'un à l'autre ils
tiendront parole
il est comment ou si tous y est plus
simple qu'est ce que vous faites demain
matin à 11h10 rien pourquoi parce que
moi demain matin à 11h10 je vais
identifier des empreintes digitales dans
un appartement vide
oui on a tout volé sauf le oui c'est une
chance inespérée vit avec moi jamais je
vous aime mais je ne ferai appartenir à
un homme dont je ne porte pas le nom
vous oubliez que je suis la fille du
curé de notre dame de la république
ah oui c'est vrai j'avais oublié ça j'ai
jamais pas plus d'ailleurs comment un
tueur et pouvait avoir une fille
je croyais s'était défendu mon père est
entré dans les ordres qu'à 24 ans
j'étais déjà menées depuis quand ça vous
regarde pas non pardon devant vous
admettez que la fille d'un
ecclésiastique ne peut pas avoir un
amant le divorce ce soir c'est déjà très
grave et l'adultère non 6000 hommes
adultères et faisons nous pas assez les
torts de mon côté mais vous êtes fous
mais vous dites le divorce ce soit je
suis trompé oui je suis victime
les larmes aux yeux je réclame la
séparation la provoc et moi dans ma
faute
pensé à mon père non la famille enfin je
vous conseille de parler et battront pas
quoi mais alors vous oubliez tous
aujourd'hui quelle est la teneur exacte
du testament de rentrer non arbitraire
et d'un poignet oui j'ai hérité lui à la
condition que j'épouse yvonne mais en
pas de divorce
toute la fortune revient à celui en
faveur duquel le jugement sera rendu
vous voyez bien ce serait notre ménage
si nous nous faisions pincer demain
matin dans cet appartement maculé
d'empreintes digitales
l'accouplement les du bray dunes
excommunié et d'un mendiant
vous avez raison c'est impossible alors
oui au bonjour monsieur le préfet mais
c'est impossible qu'il est impossible qu
au bout d répondu de la sorte de chez
monsieur bridge non c'était une erreur
pardon demain à 5h c'est entendre
bonjour monsieur le préfet chez lui
demain à 5h voilà voilà la femme qu'ils
me font pleurer a dit oui et quand on
cause on pour que nous soyons l'un à
l'autre il faut donc que deux dimanches
ce soit pendant oui simplement
mais un autre défense il faudrait que
vous surprenez votre femme avec un amant
c'est vous ce a annoncé moi ça il
voudrait que vous surprenez votre mari
avec une maîtresse ou votre femme avec à
la manche
or mon mari ne pense qu'à moi et ma
femme ne pense qu'à voir il faut
pourtant arriver à nos fins
si je suis résolu à tous moi aussi
savez vous ce que j'ai fait hier matin
non figurez vous que notre femme de
chambre nous a brusquement quitté
célestine pourquoi parce qu'elle allait
déjeuner en ville que je refusais du
hajj l'un des cinq enfants y avait plus
de maison c'est bien vrai aussi pour la
remplacer je ne suis pas allé dans un
bureau de placement
ah non non je suis allé dans une maison
dont vous êtes garé dans une maison où
l'on retrouve des filles pelé soumises
je me suis je et dont on n'a pas besoin
d'agrafés la honte parce qu'elles n'ont
pas haut
vous avez été dans un plat étaient dans
un bus
alors j'ai demandé la directrice elle
est plus et mat bonjour belle rousse tué
plaidant tu as tout à fait le genre de
la maison
le nous sommes complets en battant d'un
mois alors je lui réponds dire non je
suis une béance comment pierre jarry
répondu non je suis une cliente et je
viens seulement vous demander si vous
pourriez me prêter pour quelques temps
une personne qui s'habilleraient en
femme de chambre et qui seraient
susceptibles d'émouvoir mon mari elle a
beaucoup ri elle a appelé carmen bon je
lis agréable bon plus tonique celestis
nous sommes tombés d'accord sur les
conditions là tout de suite commenté son
saint lô
qu'entendez vous par ses paroles bell a
servi le dîner d'abord au pardon bon
assez mal en bas c'est pas son métier
ensuite elle est allée faire le lit de
mon mari il couche toujours avec une
boule
comment une chance fract situe je ferai
très bas l'inflation alors comme par
distraction
elle a posé la boule par terre et elle
s'est enfoncée jusqu'aux fondu à la
place de la chance voilà
et alors et bah alors robert est allé se
coucher
cinq minutes après j'ai été réveillé par
des cris sauvages
c'était morrison qui était au septième
ciel non c'était carmen que mon mari
venait de sauter par la fenêtre
heureusement nous habitons
rez-de-chaussée et vous voilà comme
devant sans adultère et sa femme de
chambre parlez moi de votre femme à
présent
la même chose qu'à acheter affamés de
100 par la fenêtre
non non non parce que moi je m'étais
adressé un séducteur professionnel louis
un vieil ami il a eu 417 maîtresse
ensemble en ont les unes après les
autres en main alors eh bien alors ils
von la gifler autour de moi tout ça et
d'un rapt et je sais pourquoi
c'est parce que nous nous y prenons mal
comment mais oui malgré tout l'amour que
nous avons l'un pour l'autre
ça nous agace un peu d'être trompé même
si ça nous agace qu'on nous le serons ce
sera parfait mais pour y aider
pour en prendre l'initiative non notre
amour propre et là qui nous empêche de
faire ce qu'il faut il faudrait que je
débauche votre femme et que vous non que
je débauche votre marine pas là je me
perds vous savez je suis pas depuis
longtemps dans le métier il faudrait que
je débauche votre mari est là et que
vous vous vous occupiez une ma femme ça
vous va comme ça tout va
attendu que nous soyons la nano ou
trauma collège mont victoire
elle embrasse bien alors comment
arriverez-vous ça j'ai mon idée
ah bon avez vous déjà entendu parler de
clara bouchard non pièce une femme que
votre mari adoré quand sa renommée
rassurez vous il ya longtemps maintenant
bien sûr mais comment savez-vous ça je
suis détective ne l'oublié pas l'épi
morrison on a souvent parlé il s'est tué
pour elle la balle qui l'a dans
l'omoplate gauche
eh bien il se les tirer en décembre 1913
pour clara bouchard d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça qu'il est réformé et bien depuis
huit jours je fais rechercher cette
clara bouchard vous croyez qu'ils
l'aiment encore au bas d'une femme pour
laquelle on s'est tu et ça c'est une
chose
comme dit le poète alors après eh bien
je fais rechercher cette paire à
bouchard je la retrouve
je l'amène à morrison et nous verrons
bien l'idée est ingénieuse
seulement voilà maintenant que je suis
dans sa vie je crois vous voyez vous
voyez l'amour programme non non pourvu
que vous réussissiez aux abonnements
victoire m'a collé est en moi paul est
entré pour nous
[Rires]
qu'est ce que c'est ça sert à ça mais
d'où viens-tu d'eau toi j'ai à vous dire
que diarra bouchard sera là dans un
quart d'heure 1 vous avez vu
dès que je m'occupe de quelque chose moi
un with me demandez pas comment je suis
parvenu à ce résultat ghadames tu as
suivi mes instructions et les chauffeurs
n'ont pas chers amis nous allons risque
une épreuve décisive
morrison est là c'est une chance dans un
quart d'heure à cette même place
il sera en face de clara bouchard
rentrez chez vous n'oubliez pas votre
bonheur et attendait beaucoup de
téléphone vous est admirable et non je
vous aime
habile à tous bientôt vous alors
voyez comment as tu fait pourquoi pour
retrouver clara bouchard j'ai suivi vos
instructions enfin je t'en prie nous
sommes seuls à leur raconte ben alors
que je vous raconte cette enceinte
vous savez que clara bush a invité aucun
camp royal elle a déménagé il a été
habité 22 rue d'hauteville seulement
elle a quitté l'appartement ya huit mois
c'en est cette adresse personne ne sait
où elle est alors que rien fait moi je
sais pas je t'aurais demander conseil
c'est ce que j'ai fait je me suis
demandé conseils et me suis donné un et
j'ai été visité le dernier appartement
quitter il est évident désert seulement
dans un coin partant y avait une
photographie qui représentait un
académicien avec une belle barbe blanche
et des moustaches et il y avait cette
dédicace à ma chère fille clara bouchard
son père académiciens et alors real ans
et de 20 ans je suis descendu lé demandé
des renseignements à la concierge femme
charmante qui a des ennuis d'argent
elle a un pied bot une boîte rythmes
endiablés ça ça n'a absolument rien
n'avance
alors il me donne des renseignements
inutile et vad
un seul prix lma vous que durant tout le
séjour de clara bouchard beauteville
clara bouchard tous les jeudis à 5
heures à léo digne hall des
champs-elysées elle adorait le digne de
change et du céleri et belges et des
souris mais commandes et heureusement
qu'elle jouerait ton jeudi quelle heure
est il
cinq ans avant alors il ya trente
minutes après m'être fait la tête de
ligne ce travail art après avoir revêtu
l'habit d'académicien jeu surgissait au
digne des champs elysées 1000e femme se
lève ici pris au mot père papa moi
j'ouvre mes bras elle tombe d'origine et
toi tu es clara bouchard elle me dit oui
je suis clara bouchard mais elle ajoute
mais vous mon père comment se fait-il
que vous soyez là vous êtes membre
depuis dix ans et oui
alors je lui dévoile tout j'explique
elle comprend une salade en dix minutes
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez
remuant tu viennes lui rendent un très
bon service à je te fais tous mes
compliments ravelli je le mérite
au menu les vignes maintenant oui
parle-moi un peu de clara bouchard oui
elle et elle est jolie
il va mon dieu elie battant m'attendais
pas que je n'avais pas envie de ça dont
je vais dire bonjour plus fatigués
pardon monsieur aumont sur monsieur
monseigneur moi même une entreprise
restez couvert monsieur je suis il
embrasse bien
bon alors je donne je m'en vais quelle
heure est il dès 17h55 six en six mois 5
et félicie qui m'attend au 6e invente je
m'en vais travailler au dictionnaire à
la lettre à abou ajoura toujours quand
il m'envoie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec une émission de mes amis à qui on a
volé je vois un sujet de roman non mais
je voulais retrouver ça il ressemble
anatole france c'est lui il pousse les
dieux ont soit pas bon non viens-tu
agrumes présentés ont tu sais les
académiciens les hommes de lettres les
auteurs dramatiques
il faut pas trop les connaître il faut
les admirer mais assez haut mais il vaut
mieux ne pas les connaître a sans doute
raison j'étais venu te dire que j'ai
raisonné ta krabey lescalmel tas d'or tu
as tort de ne pas être plus gentils avec
elle elle est charmant je t'en prie
laisse moi tranquille avec ma femme bon
bon bon approuvé la mienne et elle vient
de sortir
il a été faire une cause mon dieu est
était si peu couverts trop vu qu'elle ne
prenne pas froid à celle aime ta femme
au delà tort c'est la créature la plus
fine la plus sensible la plus
intelligente ah oui jonathan moss
comment on chez robert de dire pas si
toi aussi tu vois là là près de moi
voilà le plus près on a des partenaires
plus près et causons suis vraiment
content de te voir
qu'est ce qui te prends tu me vois tous
les jours non mais on se voit en cause
mais on ne se connaît pas un verre de
porto
c'est ça te fait plaisir oui mais voilà
aujourd'hui c'est cette attente coeur
que je veux parler aujourd'hui je veux
faire ta connaissance et bien volontiers
je suis né le 24 juin 1889 à 3 avril à
lorgues et non mais alors et je ne
demande pas ça il n'est pas question de
ta biographie
alors quoi ceignac
je n'ai jamais tu le sais très bien et
bien justement elles sont haut placés
elles sont la civ elles vont de grease
et c'est ce qu'il faut victor que les
étranges mais non mon ami mais nous
sommes là tous les deux beaux jeunes
intelligente nous buvons nous nous
fumons et nous causons librement oui et
de pas causants nous attend mais nous
causons forme et bien volontiers à
colette est un ange tu sais hélas non
non non non non ben quoi
panneaux femme légitime les autres quel
autre débat toutes nos maîtresses et
qu'est ce que tu as aujourd'hui victor
tu sais très bien que je n'ai pas de
maîtresse alors écoute tu es vraiment le
seul varie de france qui ne trompe pas
sa femme
enfin on dirait que tu ne me connais pas
son jeu dans quel principe j'ai été
élevé quelle a été ma vie ma carrière je
suis professeur de théologie ça n'a rien
de particulièrement égrillard j'ai fait
un seul livre
ils s'appellent les religions de la
haute egypte il se peut vendre un
exemplaire ben oui je sais c'est moi qui
les ai achetés cette fois j'étais mal
depuis marqué l'épousé la fille d'un
prêtre ce qui est très difficile à
trouver
infidèle un studio ou où on prendra le
temps de faire la noce mon dieu tu n'as
pas toujours été aussi froid si alors
l'envoyons tu oublie un peu vite et
confidences commencent à éclore
abouchahla tu vas aimer clara bouchard
premier amour de ma vie j'avais 24 ans
l'avait 22 elle était belle comme le
jour
grande mince mince masse très minces une
de yann
j'adore les enfants et bien c'est q
pourquoi je me suis séparé d'elle non
parce que cette femme est vague et trop
ma sensualité à l'andorre à mon cher ya
qu'à la voir elle fait exploser au moins
des trésors de sensibilité et sa durée
de deux ans deux ans tous les jours chez
nous donne en pâture au théâtre à bout
parfait quelque chose la prendre dans
mes bras c'est admirable pourquoi mais
parce que une femme qui vous fait
longtemps cet effet là c'est très rare
et si tu la voyait bien qu'assez site et
touche maintenant je vais là fait lâcher
la volonté tu as froid bon ok ça ta main
et froide les eaunois la chose mais
pourquoi me demande tout ça mais pas sur
mon ami la vie est vraiment une suite de
coïncidences étranges explique toi non
ex comment nom explique toi comme on l'a
fait tout à l'heure ça c'est rien c'est
ce que je te dise intérieur figures
comme dans une affaire dont je m'occupe
j'ai été mis en rapport par le plus
grand des hasards avec une certaine
clara bouchard dont l'âge et le
signalement de répondre exactement l'a6
et l'a8 est bien jadis rue quincampoix
sisters et lien social
alors tous la revue tous leurs voix la
voilà cette haine de la réplique à la
cage vide
si je la revois je ne réponds pas moi
alors on touchera entre et madame
[Applaudissements]
peut-être un peu apprécié depuis que je
vous ai dit si si si si je m'en rends
compte
mais ce sont des bébés de chacun et si
vous avez plusieurs enfants voilà donc
pas là ils ont sans doute pas là si pour
nous consoler de votre abandon robert je
me suis jetée dans la maternité mais
j'ai voulu que mes enfants soient tous
parfaits intelligent et beau aussi c'est
avec beaucoup de soin que j'ai choisi
leur paie vous vous êtes mariés
maintenant à non pourquoi
non le père de mon aîné était générale
que j'aime les militaires rêve c'est
bien dit francis il est superbe
le père du second était un poète norvège
ra un chez les pères du troisième c'est
un champion de boxe
le carreleur comme ça j'ai eu deux
jumeaux avec le président marc n'aura
non non non mais pour les autres je dois
être discrète mais c'est lui dont je
suis le plus fier c'est mon petit
dernier son service militaire
ah non il a six mois
il est dans la réserve tout m'a fait
supposer qu'il est le fils d'un conte
strays un faux nom le roi d'espagne qui
m'a remarqué à deauville l'eau traitée
sous un parasol les dates on vient tous
mes compliments à robert je suis content
que cela m'a permis de vous retrouver
mais il ne faut pas que cette rencontre
va sinon on nous nous reverrons me faire
gagner 6 kg encore voulez vous être le
père de montdidier déclara ce serait
avec joie mais je viens d'avoir les
horizons bon eh bien ce sera pour le
plaisir voici mon adresse 342 réchauffe
bon merci merci pour la grèce mais dont
la france
n'oubliez pas 342 région sera assez
parfois société doit nommer ce fut quand
même pour les enfants monsieur la
troublante de volumes et de la première
étoile
à la campagne pour palm dame
[Musique]
hp pas ta passion mon vieux à merci mais
rudement excitante à un maximum mon cher
mon fidèle mon meilleur ami l'un comme
l'autre guérir tous avec toi pour
s'arrêter à la seule capable de faire
oublier mes doigts mais tous ne l'a
montré et bien maintenant c'est fini
jamais je ne tromperai plus ma femme ça
tu peux en être sûr merci c'est raté
mais comme le big up un chantier démarre
mais qu'est ce que tu ne chantes
morrison va résonner tu sais qui tu
aimes bien morrison cette même veine m
je ne sais plus jamais insupportable
fait j'ai trouveront pas la femme la
plus douce la plus démente et tu n'auras
jamais plus le plus petit reproche à me
faire aux biens et bien et tu content ah
je suis ravi à votre santé à notre
bonheur à votre union il faut trouver
autre chose
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors madame maurice donne de quoi
s'agit-il à paris à da paris que j'ai
fait il ya un quinze jours avec mon
cousin letournel que je vous connaissez
mon cousin le tournoi - je n'aime pas du
tout c'est un des draps supportable et
prétentieux alors je suis ravi de ne pas
le connaître
figurez-vous que l'autre soit à dîner
chez lui il m'a soutenu que jamais sa
femme le trompe avec elle et si laide
que ça pouvait pas du tout et leurs
habits sont jeunes et désirable a
néanmoins il peut y croyez vous qu'il
est belle en principe elles doivent
tromper mais il faut qu'elle le trompe
pas ah bon vas y mon pari ah parce que
l'objet du paris oui la suffisance de
mon cousin m'a gazé tellement que je lui
ai soutenu qu'avant trois mois elle
tomberait dans d'autres bras que les
cieux c'est un pari charon à paris lé
parisien né à paris à la richelieu
comme dans mademoiselle de belline
d'alexandre dumas père il faut que je le
gagne
ah mais c'est pas couru j'ai choqué
l'enjeu est de 20 milles francs et que
je vous emmènerai le cas si vous m'aidez
si je réussis alors madame c'est gagné
d'avancé
ou de me blâmer tourner annonce avec
l'un de vos conseils
non votre intervention ah ben je
regrette j'étais prêt à tout tenter à
offrir pour la main sur rabut avait que
voulez-vous ici dans cette agence on
s'occupe de toutes les affaires les
mauvaises et les bonnes en ce moment je
m'occupe d'une bonne pardon oui mais
alors
revenons à mesdames les tournelles voilà
monsieur rapide depuis quelques temps
j'essaie tout tous les moyens connus et
inconnus dont on dispose pour triompher
de la vertu d'une femme je lai d'emploi
comme dans grisélidis 7 vous nous
annoncez de massenet alors nous fait le
rôle du tien et bien et bien diriger le
tas nul jusqu'à présent cette femme
reste hermétique
vous êtes un fin détective c'est vrai
mais afin lizard a sans aucun doute
alors dites moi qu'est ce qu'il faut que
je fasse si t'as faim tu m vous n'avez
qu'à prendre une photographie
oui mais de qui fait d'une femme
quelconque jolie si près 6 pts 2 j'en ai
vu plein dans mon tiroir là alors vous
dites à madame les tonnelles que vous
l'avez trouvé sous le traversant par
exemple de son mari mme vous y ajoutez
une dédicace tendent en déguisant votre
écriture et aussi d'eau hors d'elle elle
se précipite dans les bras du premier
venu d'un prince break comme dans fifi
d'albertville me souviens d'un simple
domestique comme dans ruy blas de victor
hugo à la main de sa vie j'avais pas
pensé à ça m
vous êtes d'avis que ce moyen et on me
nomme si tu manques à 'b' à 'c' il n'y a
qu'un pas où ça pourrait rater car le
cas où cette âme regarde la photo et il
demeura différentes 1 c'est à dire
qu'elle ne veut pas prendre damman alors
là c'est qu'elle est honnête non madame
c'est qu'elle en a déjà
pas vous connaissez les phares alors oui
vous pensez félicie aussi en fins
précises
alors est ce moment là c'est à moi de
découvrir le nom de cette dame en sept
morceaux ont donné dix mille francs au
lieu des cinq mille prévus et je vous
apporte notamment dans les 24 heures
je vous remercie fondateurs dont je vais
rentrer cette photographie etc ou bien
alors là je ramène un homme voilà bien
bien tiens c'est qu'elle en a déjà
ouais mais impossible qu'elles soient
simplement vertueux oh non madame la
vertu ne paye pas au théâtre garder
cornelie lucrèce eu pénélope toutes ces
femmes sont ennuyeuses incapable inutile
allez je vous laisse madame mais que sur
ce secret nos lèvres soit fermé et je
sors du bureau comme à l'accoutumée fée
mazine ah non ça c'est pas de racines
c'est moi madame
ah oui je suis prête à meilleur jeu tac
une amie quand je taquine la muse
à victor bridge mon amant en souvenir
d'eux tant d'heures inoubliable à
béatrice nous sommes le 19 je mets le 18
mai 1923
et voilà comment tu étais là mûri depuis
cinq minutes personne même prévient
pardon ça j'avais dit qu'on te préviens
pourquoi bah je me suis dit quand elle
arrivera elle arrivera mais qu'est ce
que tu as toi voyons encore là mais ils
vont en acier toi écoute moi je suis
tout ouïe
si tu apprenais donné que mon mari me
trompe
oh c'est rigolo fond du trou oui
morrison de trop pulpeuse type oui en
effet c'est impossible enfin admettons
il me trompes tu la prends alors qu'est
ce que tu fais mais comment est ce que
je la prends par une preuve écrite une
preuve irréfutable
eh bien je prends mon courage d'une main
la preuve de l'autre le taureau par les
cornes
je t'embrasse en pleurant et je te dit
tout c'est ton avis il faut se soutenir
entre fin à ça tu as raison ma chérie ma
pauvre chérie tu sais je voudrais pas
être à ta place
non ma chérie voilà bah tu trouvé par
terre dans l'antichambre l'autre soir
chez moi quand vous êtes parti après le
dîner ses étangs des élus par dessus de
ton mari ça alors que vu la dédicace à
victor bridge mon amant à ce netbook ya
rien de plus nette en souvenir de ton
der wien oubliable n'avait qu'une faute
d'orthographe
comme en écriture inoubliable toi là
comme ça tu attends à 23 15 tu crois
remarque tu peux l'écrire avec 2 mais
alors là il ya une faute d'orthographe
cela devient du dévergondage
grammaticale c'est une cuisinière cette
femme là bon allez distraite ça peut
arriver
non titularisé visagie faveur de graff
de cette femme là il s'agit de ce que tu
vas faire un c'est très simple je prends
ceci je porte à mon avoué et dans deux
mois je serai une femme libre
indépendante et riche tu connais le
testament de l'encadrer toi ben oui ça
je le connais oui bah tu as l'air
contrarié c'est pas ça qu'il faut que je
fais mais non enfin coût de cette
vengeance froid meetic les abus et les
tribunaux le code les paperasses c'est
indigne de twilight bouillon et si tu as
raison il me faut de vengeance brutale
passionnés mal là je vais le tuer fait
chercher mon petit revolver en explosifs
à risque d'y penser à ce que teddy
tinmar et j'avais dû me donner ces
photos tu as brisé ma vie tu es z
on veut que tu dois qui m'a dit tout à
l'heure que dure au père l'ancien
président américain
je suis complètement folle il était plus
que je dois faire avec moi il y a des
vengeances en sang qu'est ce que tu dis
des vengeances ans ont répondu oui pour
oeil c'est pas bête ça prendre en amont
c'est une excellente idée mais ce qu'ils
méritent
dès lors qu'ils coin battue me donnez
moi j'ai personnes sous la halle au
coton pour les hommes qui m'ont dit on
va regarder dans le bottin regarde le
bouton le gotha monde à 6 et c'est
clémenceau reconnu trouve important oui
tu as raison
alors je remonte car contre le boxeur il
est bon il est pris à oui tu as raison
ab tmc ont le la mairie trop loin alors
les dvd durant de banal au nom puis
padam en fait toute façon moi je déteste
la bourse ennuyeux toujours par il
tombait sans eau n'ont pas d'argent mais
alors toi là différents os le mépris
surnom c'est comme ça la résignation
existe-t-il quelque part un mari fidèle
soyons résigné quand tu y trouveras une
autre photo apporte la mois si elle a
beaucoup je pas l'album viva tué étrange
je suis résigné
tu veux un peu de porto elle se moque de
moi et là un amant mais je saurai tester
bonjour les enfants
bonjour ma chérie bonjour connaît ici
pourquoi ne fait-il pas plus attention
victor à quoi il ne faut pas laisser
tomber comme ça des photographies des
tons par dessus moi je laisse tomber
j'ai songé à divorcer comme à te tuer et
ensuite à te tromper et puis je me suis
dit que sans doute c'était ma faute mais
oui je ne suis pas suffisamment près de
toi ça va changer dans deux inoubliables
comme dit la cuisinière
c'est avec moi à trépas soit tu vas
mourir à vue et me prendre comme
secrétaire en bas ça va être gentil
je te rends tu as des as tu risques et
je te pardonne je t'en conjure dit lui
qu'on n'écrit pas inoubliables comme
innovation s'est lui dit tu me rejoins
par la série mais oui c'est une petite
chérie
vous trouvez ça très ingénieux
ac oui à victor bridge mon âme ans à
béatrice mais on connaît très bien votre
écriture
où avez vous trouvé cette photo là dans
le tiroir enfin vous avez eu tort de
choisir celle là pourquoi c'est madame
bessard banquy sa belle elle a tué son
mari à montmorency
elle a découpé en morceaux et après
alors vous l'avez daté d'hier elle est
en prison depuis un an
mais qu'est ce que ça peut faire enfin
écoutez je ne peux tout de même pas la
posséder dans sa cellule
les règlements s'y opposent qu'est ce
que vous allez chercher là il vient
capable dans deux familles sur cette
photographie alors c'est bien traiter
votre yapi l'aimé et c'est yvonne l'a
reconnu pensez vous ça expliquerait le
calme relatif avec lequel elle a
accueilli votre petite histoire du tout
j'ai consulté à son calme vient de ce
qu'elle a déjà un amant tu voteras
femmes
non non non qui l'homme qui l'homme à je
ne sais pas encore mais je saurai oui
alors là ça m'étonnerait comment pouvez
vous croire tu veux sur votre amour
prend après la collecte ou voulez-vous
être libre oui ou non mais je ne pense
qu'à ça et vous mais je ne vis pas pour
autre chose
eh bien vous ça y est pardon je dis vous
ça y est vous allez être libre morrison
a une maîtresse ça dépendrait quand vous
voyez vous voyez l'amour propre
aucun amour propre et nioc de
l'incrédulité comment voulez-vous que
jade maître robert
ce théologien moraliste s'y ranger votre
iphone oui mais robert non ma petite
colette je ne sais pas à quoi vous
arrivez avec yvonne mais je sais que
vous me fait beaucoup rire avec la vertu
de robert ah bon ah non alors expliquer
non mais réfléchissez donc pourquoi at
il jeté par la fenêtre cette pauvre
fille a mené par vos soins est habitué à
des maisons plus tolérante
pourquoi qu'il refusait de faire un
sixième enfant à cette bonne française
comme poids désiré et encore désirable
oui si on veut
pourquoi mais parce qu'ils m'adorent me
pour vendre mais parce que depuis cinq
ans il est l'amant de madame est belle
5 rue dumont d'urville vous êtes sûr de
ce que vous dites oui parce que moi je
suis détective free ne l'oublié pas
alors mis pour mieux de jouer alors
qu'est ce que vous avez fait aujourd'hui
à trois heures j'ai cueilli morrison à
la sortie de son cours
oui je mettais déguisé en balayeur à
balayeur borgne ivrogne sentant l'alcool
et guy pas impossible qu'ils le
reconnaissent d'ailleurs je me suis
regardé dans une glace c'était pas moi
je m'aime pas si c'était une blague
d'ailleurs et à 30 mètres derrière lui
je n'ai pas quitté de la journée
raconter la 4 journée
il a descendu le boulevard raspail
il est entré chez un libraire et il en
est ressorti avec une grande quantité de
journaux je le reconnais bien là il en
achète 20 par jour
allez après après il a pris le boulevard
saint germain il l'a descendu jusqu'à la
concorde en date au nom à pied tiens il
déteste marché oui bah c'est pourtant
ainsi alors il a traversé la seine en
bateau en bateau non non à pied à pied
en passant le pont il s'est approché
près du parapet il a regardé logiquement
il a versé quelques larmes
pourquoi mais j'en sais rien je ne
déduit pages raconte place d'iéna à
proposer je savais pas que morrison
aimait les chiens mais il a toutes les
bêtes en horreur mais pour qu'ils y
mensonge il les ados et comment
savez-vous de sa place d'iéna
il y avait un petit faute soit non
servier qui avançait péniblement la
patte cassée au pot petit beurre
nous attendre et sont pas alors morrison
l'a pris dans ses bras et l'a porté chez
un pharmacien vous en êtes sûr je le
suivais à 30 pas un peu plus loin rue
françois 1er
il y avait un gros boules de verre non
dogues n'ont pas asthmatique propos
petit pet ne nous attendre et sont pas
qu'ils avaient sans doute perdu son
maître et qui pleuraient assis sur son
derrière
qui ça le m non le boul alors morrison
s'est approché il a sorti son mouchoir
tout doucement il lui a essuyé les huées
mais qu'est ce que vous me chantait une
voix si l'avenue kléber au pied d'un
arbre
il y avait un petit oiseau qui était
tombé du nid du net ne nous attendre et
sur par alors morrison la ramasser il
l'a mis dans sa poche qui salent bull
dans l'oiseau france est inouï saint
remy se faisait tard alors il a regardé
sa montre il a accéléré le pas il est
arrivé 5 rue dumont d'urville et à 4h30
tapant il s'y engouffrait à lèves et
quand tu puisses en pauvres petites
bêtes
qu'est ce que vous dites le concierge
le monsieur qui vient d'entrer connaît
pas un louis je ne connais ou va-t-il
j'en sais rien de louis entre sola
gauche 4 l'oit
il vient tous les jours si louis voir
madame hébert huile oui le mari n'est
jamais là il est toujours à son bureau
je vous dis ça parce qu'ils n'ont pas
donné mais et rennes c'est combien vos
étrennes
200 francs dit louis vous les avez et
voilà comment en une fois j'ai réparé
une injustice les outils à votre niveau
mon divan quelle heure est il 5h30 vous
avancez en fait rien et bien en ce
moment même
monsieur hébert prévenu par mois et
floqué du commissaire de police surprend
morrison avec sa femme
1 qu'est ce que vous dites de sa
vraisemblable c'est que dès que je me
mêle de quelque chose moi alors vous
êtes contente je m'explique toujours pas
le petit oiseau les deux chiens non
merci bonjour bonjour mais non merci
mais d'où viens-tu de toi de ton fumoir
j'étais très fatigué par mon cours alors
comme tu n'étais pas là quand je suis
arrivé je suis étendu sur le divan j'ai
dormi deux heures
comment t'es tu étais là depuis deux ans
oui environ au nom de dieu je vous
disais que c'était invraisemblable
embrasse moi mon chéri mais avec plaisir
de ce qu'il y a y'a rien hélas
moi je réussirai à nom d'une pomme
qu'est ce que la est rien rien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'arrière morrison mon ami nous sommes
seuls dix mois la vérité tu viens bien
de la rue du mont d'youville
bon je te dis que je sors de ton fut
moins nahla la voyons voyons mettons pas
redressée je pense aller mais le quand
même une dépêche toi il n'ya pas dans la
neige mais non chapeau maintenant aux
sélections du bureau
dans l'autre sens
têtu m'ennuie je ne rêve pas morrison
non il sonne c'est bien toi oui tu as
bien été à ton coup aujourd'hui oui tu
en est bien sorti à trois heures oui tu
as bien acheté une grande quantité
journaux chez un libraire
oui tu as bien pris le boulevard saint
germain non têtu a pris un taxi je suis
venu chez toi directement directement
alors oui cela vous voyons pas de
mensonge montre moi ton petit oiseau
tu es un bon ajout dans ta poche pardon
tu la fleur est sur le pont de la
concorde et eu à essuyer les yeux d'un
gros boulet fnatic
nous savons pas mon pauvre vieux
morrison morrison il faut pas te payer
ma tête je t'ai suivi pendant deux
heures en voilà une idée pourquoi mais
parce que je suis détective c'est mon
métier je me disais je suis ému et bien
qu'on me fit bientôt atteint tu crois
mais oui pour déployer une fois que ça
arrive alors rappelé qu on si peu c'est
que cette fois là c'est très bien
monsieur très en colère qui veut vous
voir à 6 atteint je le sors mon état il
a écrit quelque chose derrière pas nom
de madame hébert diable et à des styles
veut oui vous casser la figure
molson comme ça mais c'est bien ici
paris ça fait tilt recevoir non et
thouars à but non non non
monsieur prix s'il vous plaît et je
comprends si elle par dessus une fois ci
voici monsieur brighi irin assieds toi
je suis à vous monsieur là c'est toi
dans les services haute attention a
rejoint match aura fini avec monsieur ou
plutôt quand monsieur aura fini avec
assieds toi américains canadiens pour
moi c'est un pot - les cigarettes
monsieur merci un verre de porto
non alors essayez vous à longtemps alors
comme ça vous avez ri à ma secrétaire
que vous désiriez me casser la messe le
probable messieurs ça lui prend de vous
alors qu'il n'en soit plus question
monsieur j'ai su par quelques mots du
commissaire de police qui vient de nous
surprendre en flagrant délit madame
hébert et moi que c'est vous qui avez
révélé à monsieur hébert notre liaison
ce pour quoi allez vous faites ça c'est
une erreur monsieur une similitude de
pardessus soyez gentils n'y pensais plus
besoin de méthodes vous pourriez ma vie
vous me dites ni principe lui c'est
surtout la vie de monsieur non messieurs
c'est la mienne je fréquente le ménage
hébert depuis cinq ans je suis garçon de
restaurant
nous menons non mais je suis célibataire
leur foyer et le mien j'ai toutes mes
habitudes puis et puis j'aimerais l'âme
et bellême d'une façon folle tenez
monsieur je les rencontre et ont
simplement il n'a rien fait pour se
refermer
je l'aimais pourtant d'un amour ardent
n'ont rien je le sens ne pourra me
défais khilafa bref alors nous sommes
rencontrés sur le programme mais bien
parce que depuis chaque fois que j'y pas
je pleure de joueurs et je verse une
larme en garde dans l'eau au moins nous
revient je viens de comprendre quelque
chose
continuez et puis je suis la victime de
monsieur hubert
ils m'adorent et j'ai et je le lui rend
bien
maintenant quand il est à paris nous
sortons tous les trois mois soit
d'ailleurs il n'est jamais les cantines
ou non il fait des courses à y jouer aux
courses non merci alors nous sommes
francs pour les 2,9 à vous dire que lui
est un gros voyageur de commerce et d
tout en partie sa famille est donc
presque la mienne faut vous dire que moi
je ne suis pas très occupé quel est
votre profession monsieur secrétaire
général de la société protectrice des
animaux
je comprends tout montrez-moi votre
petit trois autres
vous avez un petit oiseau dans votre
poche comment le savez-vous je
l'appellerai bouchons oui bon alors en
continu mais pour toi qui finira quand
et pour moi monsieur c'était le bonheur
la plénitude quoi et vous vous avez
incendié le paradis mais j'en suis
désolé monsieur je vous fais toutes mes
excuses ça ne suffit pas vous m'avez
séparer de ma maîtresse fâché avec ma
meilleure amie je vous donne jusqu'à ce
soir pour raconter tout ça mais comment
vraiment bien j'ajoute que si vous
réussissez il y aura cinq mille francs
votre disposition a alors que si vous ne
réussissent le meilleur à rien et ben je
renonce à tout parce qu'il y aura
quelque chose je vous vous ré hégémonie
à qui ça vous regarde pas c'est vous
donnant une malédiction
ce vieillard m'a maudit morrison n'a pas
de maîtresse mais moi j'ai toujours 5000
france
j'ai pas absolument perdu ma journée
quant à sa malédiction
premièrement il est heureux que je ne
sois pas superstitieux et deuxièmement
je m'en fiche éperdument voilà qu'est ce
que c'est que ça un col oui je vois bien
à kolda oui et il avoue non alors
qu'elle faisait il par terre dans votre
chambre dans ma chambre dans votre
chambre conjugale à yvonne et avoue oui
je sais ça veut dire que ce col
appartiennent chemise et que cette somme
il appartient ça recommence ma femme a
un amant et bien non ma collègue mcall
est inatteignable
j'en pleure j'en suis navré mais il n'y
a rien à faire
votre mari est irréprochable et ma femme
aussi
nous ne sortirons jamais les puisque je
vous dis que ce club était parfait dans
notre chambre
qu'est-ce que ça prouve distraction
d'une blanchisseuse qui traverse
appartement et qui s'aiment d'école se
sont pas sages vous plaît d'un
électricien qui répare un lustre était à
chaud malisse d'un coup de vent qui
apportent par la fenêtre ouverte le
linge du locataire d'un jour à l'abri
pour me laisser passer et inutile c'est
comme un pardessus morrison erreur
fausse piste provisoire toujours vous
est insupportable huit ans il n'y a pas
que ce com mais quoi encore il y a que
depuis que je vous ai quitté je suis à
dans le boudoir yvonne jeu qu'était je
regardais je fouillais les tiroirs je pu
verser les piles de linge et vous avez
fait tomber un peu ensuite au rendez
vous bon bon donc
donc j'étais là dans le boudoir très
seul si monsieur
la porte qui donne sur la chambre à
coucher étaient fermés tout à coup
oui je vous tends à léger bruit ça comme
des murmures des chuchotements
passionnés sans réfléchir je bondis
j'ouvre la porte depuis éclate vauban
l'électricité c'est 1 2 on disparaît
sans lui par le couloir
oui elle par la salle de bain oui je
rallume or le lit était dans un désordre
à éloquent alors et là par terre
accablant et blair il y avait ce col
vous dites il faisait sombre
vous n'êtes vous pas sujette aux
hallucinations enfin comment pouvez vous
croire qu'en plein après midi à 20
mètres de moi ma femme ne reçoivent ici
un homme chez nous dans notre propre
chambre s comme l'a évidemment ya ce col
et en plus il est faux il valait capable
de tout je voulais toujours dit de quoi
est capable une femme qui a besoin
d'amour mais danger d'être surpris
ajouta les trains accusent champ de
pluie avec un bail à lewis chocolatées
petit bien-être vous êtes détective
avant de la découvrir
élémentaire mon cher watson
c'est le col d'un homme élégant jeune
car la forme est nouvelle
les revues car les boutonnières baril il
fit enlever violemment au poète car je
vois une petite tache d'encre humble car
les cassures sont fatigués par le
manteau il a dû aller aux indes en
passant par celle ans et colombo et il
fume le cigare
tous les samedis soirs mais comment
voyez vous ça il n'importe je le vois
son nom tout à l'heure que de charge
d'abord par les domestiques
quels sont les hommes jeunes nerveux
élégant qui sont allés aux indes en
passant par ces leurres et colombo les
qui fume le cigare tous les samedis
soirs qui sont venus ici cet après midi
je vais sonné fièrement d'état doit
regarder les filles à regarder rabut
regarder rendu à accra decool nom de
dieu
courage je voulais ce pauvre iphone ou
est elle tombée
rabut et moi pourquoi n'as tu pas de
faux col oui pourquoi j'ai pas beaucoup
je te le demande a beaucoup il d'être au
chaud alors c'est pas très convenable de
recevoir les clients s'en faut qu'on y'a
pas de paix depuis 2008
il est bien à toi sokol au leur produit
est un mois sans aucun doute mais il te
va très bien on dirait ce faucon est
sans aucun doute non merci
il est donc bien à toi faut quand la
rhinite à moi était de me demande quand
je les trouvais alors bon vous l'avez
trouvé partager magique oui
ah bon dans la chambre à coucher de ma
femme par terre à côté du lit dans le
désordre est éloquent ras si c'est vrai
ben je peux pas nier bien sûr utile
possible un tué son amant et oui toi oui
avec ta gueule et tout ça ce passe dans
ma chambre sur mon entreprise ça et vous
demande pardon c'était la première fois
habituellement va ailleurs seulement
elle était pressée moi j'étais pressé
alors mais tu odieusement aussi que je
te dis c'est la première fois qu'on le
faisait dans ton lit habituellement on
ailleurs mais dans mon lit ou ailleurs
c'est tout aussi dégoûtant au bailleur
ça vous regarde la pop
comment ça ça me regarde pas alors ça
c'est un comble tu me trompe mais ça ne
me regarde pas comment je veux trop bas
d'hamra vous couchez aussi avec
monsieur x souvent non quelquefois je
regarde pas oui alors je comprends votre
mauvaise humeur
évidemment alors qu'est ce que nous
allons faire je vais te frotter à la
porte d'abord à vous devriez commencer
par elle ou la remplacerait plus vite
que moi
son tour viendra cette fois je la tiens
ça y est je la tiens tu reconnais tu
avoues télé bien ta maîtresse avril et
ma maîtresse oui eh bien tu vas me
l'écrire
on vous a eu l'idée c'est à cette seule
condition que je te garderai chez moi
c'est pas très élégant
je te garderai et je tenterai là je suis
d'accord mais monsieur surtout que je
mens pas mois de sept petits mais oui
c'est parce qu'elle a insisté luc de
plaisir à ses côtés mais oui elle elle
était pressée moi aussi en fin de
semestre
alors qu'est ce que j'écris je reconnais
je reconnais entretenir entretenir des
relations coupables on coupable rabat
quoi elle est mariée
ouais les mariés mais son mari est un
espèce de gens foutres prévu est
étudiant sous le nom c'est un jean
[ __ ] drop ou alors assad
non mais de quelle femme ne parle plus
haut depuis cinq minutes et vous non non
non a dit d'abord donc d'abord non non
non non moi j'ose pas voilà ça doit être
encore une suite de coïncidences
mais alors ce faux col la chambre à
coucher
la femme n'a dame brige ou que je suive
lactée
alors vous croyez que moi mais la bride
au cou ça me fait plaisir mais enfin
pourquoi pas mon dieu ce qui est une
question mais de félicie wihelm adore je
couche avec la bonne
moi je suis en mode et je suis un noble
alors habituellement je vais dans sa
chambre au sixième seulement aujourd'hui
je passais dans le corridor
la porte est ouverte elle faisait la
couverture alors la fin l'occasion les
yeux tendres et quelques diable aussi le
poussant à serais je te s'est félicité
hugo nos rêves là tu m'as tu me tires
akouala tu me tires avant l'arrêt je
comprends alors il vous est créé
admissible que moi et madame briques
roule alors mais si vous avez cru
admissibles il se peut qu'elle trouve
admissible que moi et elle la ville aux
rideaux radieux
enfin que je pensais ça en belgique au
danemark en france en titre troll mais
figurez-vous malheur que votre mari
croyais que c'était ma maîtresse alors
les besoins toujours que lui et pourquoi
cette idée stupide et enfance dans ma
chambre et je vais y arriver je vois ça
continue mais n'en faites pas trop mais
s'il vous plaît
oui c'est moi seul avec mon à brive mais
je tiens à vous dire que j'ai passé là
une minute et ce qu'ils aient smatis en
conf lattes et d'être mieux que la boxe
[Applaudissements]
après mon amant maintenant on peut se
tromper
j'avais crevé à certains syndicats puis
rabut évidemment ça m'étonnait non
merapi ou un autre je suis au dessus de
tout soupçon
mais bien sûr mais c'est parce que je
t'aime alors forcément je suis jaloux
c'est sans doute par jalousie que tu met
constamment mazères tuer les femmes tu
as le vertueux tu es les banques on ne
fait pas de trancher réfléchi je suis
sûr que toutes les occasions toutes les
tentations amoureuse qui se multiplient
depuis quelques jours dans m'a dit c'est
toi qui les fait mais bon
reste une chance je n'ai pas envie de
chanter jacut moi je wind trois fois ce
monsieur qui est venue il ya quelques
jours de faire des déclarations
saugrenues que je ne connais pas ces
teintes et amis cette photo que colette
m'a montré tout à l'heure et qui sort
d'un tiroir et 7 pédicure que tu m'as
envoyé ce matin
cette pénurie emmanuelle et d'épée dont
chiromancienne elle m'a lu dans les
lignes des pieds et m'a prédit que je
mourrai dans trois mois si je ne prenais
pas un amant n'en écoute moi je me rends
pas hier c'est un docteur stationné qui
me fait mettre toute nue pour regarder
ma gorge et votre machine entière
c'était une marchande à la toilette tu
m'offres 20000 frau ont passé une heure
avec monsieur jan kopp tous armés comme
c'est vrai semble donc je te prends mais
tu vas finir victor joseph cua taissy
territoire depuis quand on fumoir
j'aurais d'être free tu sais pas
pourquoi je suis réveillée par un baiser
sur la bouche c'était trop salie tacos
musil hier et alors là je te jure t ry
pour rien oui je ne fais pas aujourd'hui
il m'arrive de si étrange aventure
depuis quelques économies qu'elle a
inventé ça que je retrouve ici comme par
hasard ce monsieur que tu suis tantôt
croyant que c'était moi les collectes il
est dans mon vin découlerait excitant et
moi j'ai du poivre dans tous les plats
trajet des reculs le dire
la sonata et moissac exemplaire de la
garçonne le pire des romans érotiques et
10 exemplaires du kama sutra avec toutes
les graves quoi quoi quoi qu'est ce que
ça veut dire
vous faites une arrivée ma femme
semblait tout à coup plus naturellement
ils sont d'accord pour tous et maka mary
alors coiffé pas sûrs de nous qui nous
est propre et en remet à saw vi et vous
m'embêter je ne comprends rien à toutes
vos histoires se comprend très bien que
ça c'est toi c'est toi et ses collègues
et mal victoire c'est très bien c'est le
mari le plusieurs réponses classées la
femme la plus fidèle
vous avez tort de nous prouver que la
shdm avait prévu habitants il ne faut
pas suffi
[Rires]
voilà ce qu'il fallait que tu entends
c'est fini oui eh bien c'est entendu
j'ai épousé la femme de césar et tu es
saint antoine en personne parfait je le
crois je me rends et je ne vous demande
qu'une chose c'est de bien vouloir me
[ __ ] la paix alors beau soir ma femme
et bonsoir mon ami
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est étrange de plus en plus étrange
pour moi il ya quelque chose entre 2
évidemment il s'agit d'accords et dans
quel but tout ça dans quel but
ne nous affolons pas non laissons passer
la nuit
réfléchissons chacun de notre côté
moi un parent est grave
nous en parlerons demain bien
tranquillement à quelque 80 chez nous
comme d'habitude ma lumière leurs atouts
oui c'était l'anniversaire de ma six
mois nous sommes allemands non nous le
fait je t'adore prend melaine
non quand je pense à ces deux là croit
qu quelques cochons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mélusine
je peux plus
à
aujourd'hui marie sara voilà
oui c'est vous qui fait mon boulot
madame dupont alors j'étais collé des
genres quoi me choque la maîtresse m'a
foutu une demi-heure de piqué alors je
restais à l'école jusqu'à maintenant mr
on va comprends pas ces noms ici pour
mettre bon ordre
oh vous savez bien que non et concierges
aller tout seul être pas quitter l'aj
épique la grille de 5e sani juillet
emménager cette croyance qui vient monde
à preuve que quand on a fait les
éclairages maintenant sur l'écriteau la
concierge est dans l'escalier
l'ars a ajouté madame famille juillet
son 5e à droite parce que ça sent le
renfermé il ya deux jours qu'on n'est
pas bien ici on s'en aperçoit
vous ne posez pas lumière cette poule
était malade déjà prié d'appeler ma
poule l éducation mon dieu oui ans
l'école communale niveau pourquoi est-ce
que tu écoles et ce après midi es4 me
suicide on arrête par un petit garçon il
perd pas ton autant c'est exact
on va aller dans l'ana cocheren grande
courtisane wimbledon dont un coup de
plumeau sur la commande c'est gratuit
vous avez grandi mais comme ça la
poussière
vous arrivez quoi j'ai la croix mes
compliments
jay a été première en géographie
grâce à vous on a juste demandé ce que
vous m'aviez a pris la dernière fois les
influents de la garonne lesquels sont
ils les influents de la garonne
je les ai oubliés depuis ma croix je les
ai oubliés mais jour l'examen gelé vous
quittez alors je laisse à rêves à la
fesse qu'on va faire mesure 10 ans comme
moi que ce qu'on va faire
ah oui qu'est-ce que vous allez
m'apprendre en attendant votre mon mari
j'ai pas du goût de tous là et bien
alors comme ça tu veux être instruite
oui mais grande courtisane faute ça toi
gatwick sans ça c'est des cons bien
qu'on en voit qu'on décore les perles
qui sont d'une ignorance
alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui
et bah tu vas faire la chambre tablette
toilettes à tout à l'heure quand il sera
là en attendant racontez moi l'histoire
d'henri iv aux attentes et trois fois ça
fait rien et bâle-mulhouse j'adore les
assassinats et puis j'ai vu jouer un
petit hôtel que des gobelins
oh la la c'est et bat la sas à la chose
à redire oui il ya une belle perruque
poudrée
il avait tort pourquoi pour rien tu m'en
ennuie avec ton henri iv à monsieur
maurice ans
[Musique]
soit suivons qu'est ce que tu veux
travailler
qu'est-ce qu'il doit succéder à bien son
nom pas du tout louis xiii son brouillon
très jeunes s'éclatent et louis xii
alors qu'il est bien avant les minéraux
résidence pour autant pas c'est quel
numéro milliard aux numéros premier du
nom pourquoi pourquoi parce que la
révolution est passée par là mais je
t'en prie procédant par an après louis
xiii et non pas tout de suite mis
quatorze week-end du 16-17 binaire sais
c'est facile
disney a pris 18 multinationales alors
là vous avez vous la prise de la
bastille et la convention consulat 1 et
nous voyons un peu trop vite faudra un
peu plus de méthode
qu'est ce qui te prochain oui le coin
teva de gentillesse de ma femme comme ça
des choses
tu aimes bien mélusine se vit sans
fleurs 7 crapulerie qui s'éveille jouant
toi paris à l'état de larve mais encore
vas-y sentent la sirène maudite pour qui
des fortunes seront engloutis les
existences tranché il me plaît de
travailler dans l'ombre cette grande
oeuvre morbide
quelle est la capitale de la russie et
une opinion et moscou lors qu'est ce que
c'est c'est un décret oh la la la
littérature j'adore ça parler ou encore
great et ratures la littérature
d'annunzio à main tandis qu'ali pourquoi
pas mal on les secours ancien label
gillon fond merci monsieur harrison je
vous aime bien ri si jamais vous avez un
navarro lequel sait-on jamais
votre femme marie de bois de poules pas
pourquoi pousser la team passera pas
ne t'en fais pas ça va être chaud c'est
si pratique une entrée son tarif est de
vous une autre sur la rue d'aumale ma
main des pâquis première est une femme
de sens aujourd'hui à penser des
frayeurs ce qu'il faut faire comme je
vais faut sauvegarder sa réputation
aujourd'hui j'écris par les gobelins de
taxi 3 microns et wade bout et bien
voici bouger les bâtons j'utilise aller
jusqu'aux près du jour là j'ai aimé un
acteur se passer dans le ciel il s'est
pas arrêté alors j'ai pris l'autobus
puis un fiacre le dernier aspect depuis
le métro et de taxi j'irai ya des fortes
je range tout ça prend 2,45 qui vous
fait rien c'est la réaction
pourquoi quand ça pourquoi vous vous
déguiser chaque fois que vous êtes ici
me dise pas beau mais on est oui vous
êtes mes lapins et oui c'est embêtant de
la dépouille d'un retrait mes scrupules
son rôle quand ce fut mais voilà que ça
vous reprend vous dites des choses qu'on
ne comprend pas le veston printanier
aiguë un voluptueux a failli sur les
épaules
un vieux morrison bonjour rampi caisse
comprendra mason d'hyperactif demain
quand j'avais des habits noirs
en ce moment je ne pourrais te parler
que de messaline des casanova et du
marquis de sade
le voilà maintenant
mais que j'ai avant lui la primeur de
télé le projet malibu moment paisible
as-tu réussi à quoi ma femme dont maaf
et toi visible alors qu'est-ce que toi
eh bien je pense qu'ils nous aiment trop
et qu'ils veulent et prouver notre vertu
ou non quant à l'or il se doute que nous
nous aimons est venu séparer la zone
alors ce sont deux êtres des esprits
taquins ils font ça pour s'amuser une en
partie alors qu'il est dans la vie à toi
ils sont amoureux l'avion donc réfléchi
et tu verras que ça crève les semaines
ils sont aussi leurs garçonnière non ils
sont bien trop tortueux et bien trompé
femmes
ils veulent s'épouser et pour cela
obtenir deux titans et si possible hibou
n'y réfléchis tu verras qu'il n'y a pas
d'autres explications à leur compte au
ballet du propos de ces combinaisons
blanches nous faire ça mais nous nous
des amants magnifiques des abominations
de nous sommes aimés nous ne sommes pas
sans calculer son combiné une escale aux
personnes une guettant ils ne rendront
pas nous nous cachons pas pourquoi qu'il
sait je suis ici au genre vient pas
connaître amoureuse de ton agressif de
barack obama non c'est pas grave et si
lille est stupide seulement dans son
métier
non non c'est colette que tu une cruche
et cela toutes les minutes
d'abord elle est jolie elle est banale
rousset fade
on dirait qu'il n'a jamais regardé
victoire avec son marteau
avec ses yeux oui nous nous disputons on
a eu des mois à porto et oublions ces
conspirateurs tu as tout à fin de
journée oui c'est pas bien que la shdm
est prête
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
faut pas que j'oublie d'emportement
aujourd'hui encore des claques des chats
et ben hyper pâte en friche nature
huit ans brigue des décennies
le point du jour un autobus un piètre à
cheval le métro de taxi j'en peux plus
loin et dire que c'est peut-être encore
monsieur jules et son petit oiseau que
j'ai suivi à long beach allons bridge
confiance conscience entourage
ça c'était une garçonnière ça c'est
l'antichambre et ce à la chambre à
coucher occupé par deux personnes dont
l'une du doigté trop morrison et être
bien lui c'est vrai ça chapeau
c'est un chapeau le flair il ressemble
bien à celui de morrison mais vous allez
partir à le signer rm peut-être encore
une coïncidence
rm robert morrison évidemment mais
peut-être roland boutard rigobert moche
république monarchique
je ne crois plus en moi c'est horrible a
cependant on dirait bien son pardessus
on dirait toujours son pardessus
templiers tailleur livrés le 4 vite 22
ans monsieur morrison je ne me suis pas
trompé c'est la première fois
il est là il est là je le tiens mais je
tiens le divorce du col est il n'y a pas
un moment à perdre
serait ce un téléphone c'est un
téléphone le flair allô allô elysées 002
fois à l'eau nageant ce bridge c'est toi
vu ici c'est bridge parlons bah tu vas
courir immédiatement au commissariat du
9e arrondissement
là tu verras monsieur veine avant le
commissaire sous le prix à devenir
immédiatement 191 rue taitbout au
rez-de-chaussée un flagrant délit
extrêmement urgent non non non non non
non je ne me trompe pas non oui cette
fois j'en suis sûr qu'il soit là dans un
quart d'heure c'est parfait merci à
bulle
couler tout le temps victor collecte
mais comment êtes-vous ici et vous je
suis votre femme et je ça veut dire vous
êtes ma famille j'ai suivi adolphe
humain elle est passée par les gobelins
elle a pris le métro
trois taxis je ne vais pas bien du tout
de même elle est on prêt ici ya dix
minutes je sais pas possible je suis sûr
d'une pente tromper la preuve c'est que
vous êtes ici j'étais japon où que vous
aussi vous suivez votre femme
pas du tout alors qu'y avez-vous suivi
votre mari qu'est ce que vous dites
tenez son chapeau son pardessus le flair
victor est quoi c'est admirable
écoutez moi je comprends plus rien que
je devais vous le dites l'âge
réfléchissons et déduisent j'ai suivi
votre femme
ça m'a amené ici j'ai suivi votre mari
ça m'a amené ici mais alors il se
retrouve dans cette guerre saunière ils
sont amants c'est impossible
cependant vous avez reçu ma femme ça
n'était pas un risque mais voilà les
vêtements de morrison n'y a pas d'énorme
et yvonne 1 vous avez vous une preuve
que ce soit yvonne nom de dieu il me
semble que vous une preuve
en voilà une yvonne yvonne et morrison
ils sont ensemble ils ont déjà un enfant
amen
on ne panique ne sont pas ici bat écrit
mais écoute moi n'eût été la jatte 1 et
tu n'es pas leur fille hattie à morrison
et à la dame qui est là et ça connaît
pas vous vous trompez pas ces dames
jeudi dans un bureau de placement et à
personne parce que toutes les bonnes
sont placés ne reste plus une fois
d'ailleurs la très forte pour ton
arrache tellement ça ne prend pas de
porte ou de louer deux verges de gains
vous l'avez des niveaux n'y a pas
d'erreur ne sort pas ma petite fille
écoute moi tiens voilà 100 francs je
suis le mari oui et moi je suis la femme
du coq
[Rires]
oui tu ne prends pas si bien dire
tiens voilà encore sont forts unissant
la littérature avec des images mais tu
vas tout fait surtout faire ce que je
veux dire
il y a longtemps que ce monsieur est
cette dame viennent dans cette
chaussette les voit un parfait
donc tu ne les connais pas tu n'aurais
pas dit vouer je me fous bien dedans dès
que vous m'avez donné deux enfants
est ce que vous voulez que je fasse tu
vas tu installes et là sur le palier 1
sur le palier pas sur le palmier sur le
palier et hugues étreint monsieur qui va
arriver dans quelques minutes
c'est un commissaire de police dieu
l'introduira immédiatement et d'ici là
pas un mot à personne en est où c'est
tout nous nous montrons lagarde ici les
coupables nous nous échapperons pas ça
vous fait plaisir mais mehdi donc quoi
la soif est si je porte pas moisi
bouhenia battu yb williams et non de la
poule
lc boonmee pampilles vous entendez
zibung les pompiers may cry mais sortir
pour voir pourquoi je ne viens pas et
vous trouverez votre combiné dansions ah
oui c'est très juste ça bon bah écoute
valeur porté à boire mais j'ai taparole
pas un jour pensé pour 200 francs je
vais leur dire que la rue les calculs
salon est vide et qu'ils peuvent ce
pagne était bien tranquille mais
pourquoi tu leur diras rien du tout
tiens voilà encore son frère merci comme
ça sera relié tu veux tu sors mon
histoire la littérature les grande
courtisane fox à soyaux instruite et la
gloire au
puteaux doit regarder te souviens encore
très ensemble et en pyjama léonard
photographe en chambre spécialité de
nuque est jeune on ma chère amy je ne
sais pas si vous avez déjà éprouvé la
sensation d'être remis dedans technique
je vais chercher saqqara bouchard je
fais des pontons et photographes
ces jeux bouleverse la famille hébert et
monsieur jules la généreuse rappelé pour
vous féliciter tout ça pour arriver à
quoi faut comprendre quoi qu'ils sont
ensemble alors les pouces et un adulte
et oui mais j'en sais rien mais tant
d'assurance niveau crise at wanadoo de
loin pensez à ces formidables annie pas
croire yvonne yvonne qui avait l'air du
temps mais mes modèles robert s'était
attaché à sa mort à vis de la débauche
et mon isolement
tu es bon chez ces terres qui a du sens
donné du mal pour le séduit de
branchez-vous
c'est cette espèce de jésuites ce gendre
de culasse venant prix
mon père n'a rien à voir dans tout ceci
non mais c'est parce que vous me dis que
c'est yvonne est légal âmes de tout
d'abord je voulais toujours dit et a
pris le mari de sa meilleure amie et
morrison que jamais comme un cochon je
suis révolté si révoltés et ont chanté
comme ans a enchanté
mesdames c'est un peu écoeurant comme ça
sur le moment mais mais c'est inespéré
c'est vrai tu es membres des diverses
une pinte est mis à nu mais il faut
aussi penser ma colette
enfin nous allons être là alors je n'ai
pas trop tu auras je crois quand je
pense que nous avions des scrupules que
nous faisons du platonisme pendant que
nos c'est vrai ce que vous dites c'est
une huile en haut je suis indigné mais
comme je vous ai ma colère et ma
collègue ou est ce qu'on la voit la
victoire
ma colère est vu que mon mari m'a dit
après vichy non il m'a dit tu sais je
viens de me brouiller avec michel alors
je vais demander pourquoi il m'a répondu
c'est parce qu'il dîne avec blanchet qui
trompe sa femme pour le tartuffe ou le
gie suite au logement ses listes mais
tout ça est loin dieu merci nous allons
rattraper le temps perdu victoire à
colette
savez-vous ce qu'elle m'a dit à moi hier
soir ça yvonne non elle m'a dit 'il
faudrait que j'aille me confesser demain
au lieu de samedi
j'ai vu un chien une chienne qui fait
régner dans la rue je n'ai pas détourné
les yeux qu'elle chine
yves robert qui s'est amené à la croix
donc à renvoyer la cuisinière parce
qu'il disait vous feront un jour en
wagons et la volée jeunes bat avec un
monsieur myope qui lui avait caressé le
jeu nous croyons que c'était sa valise
heureusement je sais pas marcher il
était tellement mieux qu'ils auraient
tous les sens on aperçoit voit alors un
autre je vous en prie parlons de nous
nous ont vite on a collé à ça quand ils
vont devoir entrer tous les deux avec
eux et puis tutoyons que tu as raison de
ma télé retient pour les jours aux
mâconnais ont été enfin jeudi vont
[Applaudissements]
encore payer constaté le seul commerce
vous avez noté monsieur le commissaire
donne moi tes lèvres encore ma maîtresse
pour la main à sa démission mais d'où
viens-tu d'entre eux en cours
directement gers une lettre anonyme me
disant que tu avais des relations
coupables avec ma femme est titulaire
savez dans cette garçonnière
heureusement j'ai rencontré le
commissaire a également averti ta femme
elle va arriver d'un instant à l'autre
norris hall et musique
alors ça comme tullow ça dépasse tout ce
qu'on peut imaginer
moi aussi arnaud alors la plaisanterie a
assez duré
elle fait la une + entre non ose dire au
commissaire tu n'étais pas dans cette
chambre avec ma femme est aussi mouiller
qui ne m'avait pas parlé mon mari j vous
qu'est ce qu'il rate le remords fait
tenir des propos insensés la colette
nakhonay ton c'est en patron t ce sont
deux autres personnes qui sont dans
cette chambre dans la personne alors
monsieur le commissaire malon la musique
on a des petites vieilles c'est notre
fille une enfant ça ne sait pas mentir
celle ci va nous éclairer monsieur le
commissaire quel est le locataire de
cette dernière c'est vous c'est bon vous
retrouver madame ici tous les jours
depuis six mois dans tesla aussi
monsieur le commissaire roman mais 300
francs
je ne t'ai pas donné 300 francs tout à
leur petit poison si pour les garçons
dégage
je vais la chambre et le cabinet de
toilette vous deviez deux mois 150
francs 2 x 154 fois sa baignoire procès
sur ce mont gerbier des joncs valoir
françois barat football s'en fout mal
quand je me sens devenir infanticide à
barcelone
ma chère amie il n'ya pas insisté je
crois que nous sommes refaite et une
indignité
j'espère que cela vous suffit comme ça
parce que le commissaire parfaitement
[Musique]
fait mais malheureusement j'ai pas été
chercher le commissaire de police
ça fait la quatrième voie goût de me
demander d'aller le chercher quand il
faut pas alors c'est pas si je me suis
méfié les issues pas aller quand elle ne
faut pas l'ont parfaitement
la première fois c'était je me souviens
bien pour un à parce que soi disant
monsieur bridge aurait arrêté
or j'arrive avec le commissaire et je
constate que monsieur brych et ligotée à
une chaise et que la page avait foutu le
camp
mauvais effet pour le connaissant la
seconde fois c'était dans un meeting
mais chez bridge avait arrêté un homme
qui brandit cet art évolue à lille avait
conduit au commissariat
c'était le préfet de police il avait
arrêté le préfet de police et fait
déploré la troisième fois c'était une
histoire de constat il demande au
commissaire de venir d'urgence pour
constater que madame gondrecourt était
avec son amant or le commissaire arrive
il se trompe de maisons et le
commissaire constate que c'est sa propre
femme que ton conversation galette avec
un coureur cycliste
big n ont vraiment des télés voler un
commissaire de police
je n'aurais rien fait et j'ai eu raison
parce que je savais que vous les pieds
pas fort mais tout de même à ce poids là
convoqué le commissaire de police
uniquement pour se faire pincer soi même
c'est ce que j'ai vu que plus idiot dans
tout matériel mais c'était pour les
surprendre eux imbéciles à elle pas
besoin de parler d' option puisque je
suis pas le commissaire allez je vous
laisse des impôts maintenant en droit je
te prie de ne pas t'en aller à vue ce
n'est pas le commissaire soit mais pour
l'étal hd félonie de ces deux personnes
j'ai besoin de témoins loyal ouais et à
passer à la bombe et l'amour dans la
vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité et les yeux dans les yeux les
tenir
[Applaudissements]
et puis ne parlait pas tous les pros
même temps un je m'en vais oui merci je
prends pas mieux monsieur bridge vous
avez joué cet appartement pour
rencontrer madame maurice à l'union
j'appelle la vérité c'est qu'à soigner
rita eux ce sont eux qui sont amants
maudits serpent
sur ma foi le professeur en théologie et
devant vishnou et bagues à bata qui
m'écoutent je choisi exprès les dieux de
l'inde parce que c'est toi le plus
rancunier je n'ai jamais pensé une
seconde à devenir l'amant de sa femme
alors tu es devenu sans même y penser
c'est plus informe que tout s'est il n'y
a plus la bâtisse ne dit pas je ne suis
pas la maîtresse comme harrison l'aurait
écouté je ne suis pas mais on a su tenir
lundi
non mais écoutez enfin cette canadienne
des vêtements la photographie son
apparition à moitié nue devant cette
porte pendant un temps mais les ij
l'avion commençait à tout embrouiller
savoir
nous les trois mêmes d'un joueur avait
compris est ce qu'on va permettre d'être
non vous irez total non mais c'est pas
pour ça c'est pour parler à ma part je
voudrais bien voir la lettre anonyme qui
t'a instruit que je retrouverai colette
ici à j'ai menti à monsieur maurice
lorsque les troyens que vous étiez le
commissaire il ya de cela dix minutes et
on le dit la vérité que depuis trois
minutes et c'est que ça c'est exact
alors commence à vivre nue trouver ici
répond toi monsieur marie san mames où
l'église est bien simple nous savions
votre manie de nous espionner de nous
suivre alors nous sommes dit on va les
amener dans cette garçonnière ils vont
croire que nous sommes à man ils
voudront se venger et on les passera
tous les sales draps
si les héritiers c'est amusant cet engin
de souscription soit pas lite amis soyez
polis alors vous prétendez vous être a
fait suivre exprès mais tu n'as pas
remarqué que depuis quelques temps jeté
par terre des petits bouts de papier non
nam est fait pour que tu ne nous perdent
pas parce que je te connais tu m'en suis
toujours un autre we hate activée il a
ensuite toujours non
wall a prêté peut-être fait suivre on
s'y exprime évidemment même que j'ai
pris par les gobelins enfin est-ce que
j'aurais plus rejoint aussi compliqué si
je n'avais pas voulu faire croire que je
craignais d'être suivi sa vue si tout
droit comme d'habitude
ça se fait quand on désire pas laisser
supposer qu'on a la crainte d'être suivi
attendez laissez supposer qu'on a la
crainte d'être mais c'est parfaitement
clair et je vois pas pourquoi monsieur
bridge supposerait que madame monique
rencontre ici monsieur morrison
voilà très bas bord annonce a par
exemple venant et des tirs à colette il
n'ya plus d'amitié
ils sont irréprochables enfin alors vous
ne demandez pas si nous vous demandons
par deux bouts on leur pardonne
soyons grands comme vous êtes jeune et
je vous félicite les gars que vous être
prêté à une conversation aussi loyal il
une explication aussi vous non plus bon
nous surveiller la branche alors il faut
cesser de se voir non mais il faut
changer de personnes brap je vous
félicite tous les deux que vous êtes
vous seulement ils sont trop forts à la
rendez vous demain dans l'appartement
vide maculé d'empreintes digitales et
maintenant laissez moi vous poser 2 3
pression est plus heureux tout content
vous vous aimez
alors la morale est sauve enfin tout on
voit une certaine morale vous former
tous les quatre un très joli quatuor que
dis-je un toi toi entre joly quadrille
où tout le monde est heureux même s'il
change de partenaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
veuillez bien m'excuser si je vous
interromps mesdames et messieurs et
petit patapon
j'apprends à cet instant cela je vous le
jure
dans ma nouvelle histoire de la
littérature quand 23 on a joué je le lis
quand c'est fun la maîtresse de bridge
de monsieur louis bernard
le plus tard on lira et c'est bien
naturel des corps de roger à costume
d'un car noël
au théâtre ce soir en télévisuelle la
mise en scène était d'un repère
m'arriver
extrait du sillon écouter la voilà
madame jacques et sardou
et me l'aviez c'est moi
jean-noël sissia
et philippe dumas
n'imaginez place
patrick préjean que cela
enfin pour terminer ce n'est pas trop
tôt voici claudine passerelle
et puis à la feydeau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]